Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
wir besprechen, was wir lesen, denn es ist während wir das hier besprechen, was wir lesen, Buchmessenzeit.
Du warst da.
Ich war heute schon eine Stunde da, hab mir das alles mal angehört und nächstes Jahr gehen wir alle zusammen mal dahin. Das braucht Begutachtung, was dort stattfindet.
Und hau ein bisschen auf die Pauke, es ist dir zu langweilig.
Es ist sehr langweilig. Ich denke mir, ich gebe die Buchmesse und die Buchmesse muss man sich jetzt wirklich so verstellen. Das sind unendliche Messerhallen. Hunderte mal hunderte Meter große Messerhallen. Und mit hunderte meine ich so 300 mal 300 Meter mehrere Messerhallen. Da finden gleichzeitig 600, 700 Talks statt. Vor jeweils so 10 bis 20, sagen wir mal 1 bis 20 Leuten. So, man kriegt immer so Wortfetzen mit. Und man denkt sich, GPT hätte kein Problem, mir aus diesen Wortfetzen das ganze 10 Minuten Talkding zusammen zu generieren. Denn ich höre dann die Romane dürfen sich in die Politik nicht einmischen, weil wir ja auch nicht wollen, dass sich die Politik in die Romane einmischt. Elger Heidenreich erklärt uns nochmal, dass wir doch leben sollten. Der Tod holt uns noch früh genug. wir bereuen nichts. Und ich denke mir, also ich sitze wirklich da und denke mir, hier muss jemand sitzen wie Frank Schörmacher. Wo ist er? Der einfach so einen ganzen Raum vor sich in den Bann und in den Aktivismus schlägt. Nicht, indem er ihnen anbietet, ich formuliere die Entschuldigung für euch. Oder ich gleite euren Opferstatus in annehmbare Worte, sondern nein, hier ist jetzt was zu tun und du musst mitmachen. Und wenn sie dahinten glauben, sie seien hier nur Zuschauer, dann ist alles verloren. Also es gibt überhaupt gar keinen zu kräftigen Aktivismus. Stattdessen sind irgendwie die Rolltreppen tapeziert mit Frank Schetzings neuem Roman. Und das finde ich auch alles toll, dass die Leute so einen Eskapismus wieder, also das finde ich auch toll. Also Frank Schetzing hat neun Millionen Bücher verkauft. Und ich denke mir irgendwie so viereinhalb Millionen davon entfallen auf der Schwarm. Also die Leute wissen eigentlich, Frank Schetzing kann ich mal was zutrauen, kauf ich mir. Stattdessen heißt sein Roman einfach Helden. Weil es könnte ja sein, dass irgendwer den neuen Frank Schetzing und dann, ja, worum geht's denn da? Ach so, Helden. Ja, dann kauf ich. Also, mittlerweile wird der Titel auf ein Wort zusammengedampft und sofort wird ihr gesagt, das ist der Sehgewohnheit entsprechend ein Heldenepos. Bitte greife zu und schaffe es, bis Seite sieben zu lesen. Also die Verzweiflung auf Angebotsseite ist, glaube ich, so groß, dass man sich das alles mal anders, man fordert nicht nur andere Perspektiven, sondern andere Vorzeichen ganz konkret.
Ich bin gespannt, wie das dann nächstes Jahr mit uns aussehen wird. Ich werde nicht in diesem Jahr auf der Buchmesse sein, denn ich habe mich immer relativ gelangweilt dort. mir ist die Luft unangenehm dort und ich habe mich schon dabei ertappt, wie ich über die Messe gegangen bin. Und nach einer Stunde habe ich Reise ausgenommen und bin dann ins Städel, habe mir dort eine Ausstellung angesehen. Solche Dinge sind alle schon passiert. Und deshalb habe ich gedacht, muss ich da nicht unbedingt hin. Aber für uns steht ja trotzdem das Buch im Mittelpunkt unseres Podcasts. Im Salon werden wir über ein Buch sprechen, das den Titel hat Verlust, ein Grundproblem der Moderne. Geschrieben hat es Andreas Reckwitz, erschienen ist es bei Surkamp. Und wir lesen dieses Buch vor allem auch deshalb, weil Reckwitz ein Soziologe ist, der von den Mächtigen gelesen wird. Zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz und Robert Habeck lesen Andreas Reckwitz, beziehen sich dann hin und wieder auch darauf. Das heißt, wir können so ein bisschen in die Köpfe der Mächtigen hineinblicken, weil wir dann dieselbe Lektüre-Erfahrung haben. Und lass mich dir die ersten beiden Sätze vorlesen. Das Buch heißt, wie gesagt, Verlust. Und es beginnt so. Tuvalu versinkt im Meer. Der Inselstaat inmitten des pazifischen Ozeans büßt jedes Jahr einen Teil seiner Landfläche ein. Da haben wir also es mit einem ganz konkreten Verlust zu tun. Und ich bin gespannt, wie er daraus dann ein soziologisches Thema macht. Denn es ist natürlich nicht einfach nur ein Klimabuch, sondern es hat mit sehr viel mehr zu tun. Es geht um so etwas wie die politische Regression, um die Artikulation historischer Wunden. Es geht um die alternde Gesellschaft, um das emotionale Selbst und die Verlustsensibilisierung, wie er das nennt. wir werden mit ganz verschiedenen Verlustschüben konfrontiert. Und ich bin gespannt, wo wir am Ende dabei rauskommen, auf welche Begriffe wir verzichten können, welche haben wir neu gelernt. Es kommen auch Altbegriffe vor, wie Populismus, Resilienz und so etwas. Verzicht selbstverständlich auch. Das wird also sehr interessant werden, weil wir ja schon über einige Soziologen gesprochen haben. Wo wird er sich dort einreihen? wird er am Ende blüde und fortschreiben oder ihm widersprechen? Viele Debatten könnten folgen.
Ich will dazu sagen, wir lesen kritisch. wir lesen nicht nur den Gegenstandpunkt kritisch oder irgendwas oder Harari, sondern wir lesen auch Reckwitz kritisch. Denn er wurde letztens in einer Pointe verarbeitet, die wir vorgetragen haben von Julia Friedrichs. Die meinte, Reckwitz hätte gesagt, die Superreichen machen das Kraut auch nicht fett. Darüber muss man nun nicht nachdenken. Nun haben wir aber von Julia Friedrichs die Aufklärung bekommen, dass irgendwie 1% der Menschen in Deutschland 30% von allem gehört und die Top Ten so 67% besitzen. Das heißt, wenn ein Soziologe ein Thema wie Verlust vorstellt und wir verrechnen nun mal Verlust in unserer durchfinanzalisierten Gesellschaft mit Euros, dann erwarte ich hier jetzt einen empirischen Einschlag, den dieser Autor offenbar vorher nicht hatte. Ich finde es zwar sehr gut, dass er in Singularitäten auch Redaktionsschluss zitiert hat und so weiter, aber nichts davon nimmt Soziologen aus der Pflicht, klüger, besser und insbesondere für ihm allgemeines Publikum zu schreiben. Außerdem einen kritischen Einschlag, der Untertitel, also dass das Buch Verlust heißt, finde ich. Ja, ein Wort, wenn ein Wort, kann man es schon ein bisschen spielerischer machen, also einfach nur einen neuen Grundbegriff vorstellen. Reicht mir nicht, weil das zu sehr einlädt, dass Merz und Habeck sich dann gar nicht auf das Buch beziehen, sondern auf die drei Folgen von Das Politik Teil, dem Podcast der Zeit, wo er einfach zu Gast ist und die drei Stunden mit ihm reden. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass das ganze Buch Verlust, was dann seinerseits ein Verlust ist, auf den Begriff Verlust reduziert wird und das Buch gar nicht ernst genommen wird. Also ich erwarte Inhalte.
So ist es ja auch ein bisschen mit der Gesellschaft der Singularitäten gegangen. Jeder hat gleich so ein Bild, es gibt eine Vereinzelung, das gemeinsame geht verloren und dann vergisst man so darüber, dass es 500 Seiten hat, dieses Buch und möglicherweise noch den einen oder anderen Gedanken präsentiert darüber hinaus.
Genau. wir wollen wissen, wie wird Verlust verrechnet, verbrieft, wie stellt er sich da, wie wird er verkauft, wer muss ihn erleiden, wer fügt ihn anderen zu und so weiter. Also wir wollen hier Butter bei die Fische. Der Untertitel lautet Ein Grundproblem der Moderne. Entweder ist es ein Grundproblem der Hypermoderne, dann ist es ein ganz gegenwärtiges Buch, das erwarte ich. Denn wir haben es hier nicht mit einem Grundproblem, sondern mit einem neuen Problem zu tun. Wenn es ein neues Grundproblem ist, umso schlimmer. Also wir sind daher unscherfen schon auf den ersten fünf Worten, die sozusagen Erwartungen wecken, die den Anspruch an das Buch steigern und nicht mindern. Ich finde den Themeneinschlag zu sagen, wir schreiben jetzt mal über den Verlust nicht schlecht, denn wir haben eine Jugendbewegung, die einfach sagt, uns ging Zukunft verloren, also haben sie ein neues Grundrecht auf Zukunft bekommen und so. Aber ja, also wir lesen kritisch. wir sind ein kritischer Bücherpodcast. wir lesen die Bücher nicht wie auf der Buchmesse, indem wir erst mal applaudieren, rechts und links, dass überhaupt ein Buch geschrieben wurde, das dann auch noch als erstes Spaß gemacht hat und dann ja auch noch einen interessanten letzten Satz hatte, sondern nein, wir wollen hier Lektüre haben.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. wir sind jedenfalls sehr nahe dann am Zeitgeist dran, wenn wir uns diesem Thema widmen und dann auch vielleicht nochmal das ein bisschen erweitern, um ja verschiedene Aspekte, die möglicherweise dann nicht vorkommen. Ich glaube aber, dass Reckwitz ja ein Autor ist, der die große These sich zutraut und das ist immer sehr angenehm, weil man dann zumindest sich auch davon absitzen kann, wenn einem die These nicht gefällt oder nicht stimmig erscheint. Und ich denke, dass wir da jedenfalls ein Buch vorgelegt bekommen, das alle in den nächsten Monaten, die so im politischen Betrieb was zu tun haben, die aber auch im akademischen Betrieb sich herumtreiben, etwas ja auslösen wird. Das ist ja immer so, dass wir bei solchen Büchern tatsächlich dann vielleicht nicht gleich eine Debatte haben, die losgetreten wird. Aber wir haben doch zumindest ein Buch, das sich anmaßt, etwas zu uns heute zu sagen und die heutigen Antworten darauf wieder. Und wenn es dann auch noch die Mächtigen sind und wir möglicherweise hier schon einzelne Vorformulierungen finden, die dann möglicherweise nächstes Jahr in irgendeinem Wahlprogramm stehen, dann ist doch damit schon einiges geworden. Ich bin jedenfalls sehr gespannt auf die Lektüre.
Ein Buch ist immer nur ein Beitrag in einer Debatte. Und umso kritischer man es lesen kann, umso besser kann das für die Debatte sein, auch wenn das Urteil zum Buch dann selbst unter die Räder gerät. Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass wir sehr inspirativ lesen können.
Das machen wir. Und wer das hören möchte, kann uns einfach abonnieren. Das geht über mehrere Wege. Wer zum Beispiel Apple-Kunde ist und es ein bisschen praktisch haben will und dem macht es auch nicht aus, 50 Cent mehr zu zahlen, kann uns einfach über Apple buchen. Dort kommt man dann in den Salon. wir empfehlen allerdings diesen Podcast, diesen Zusatzpodcast zu den Neuen Zwanzigern, via Steady zu buchen. Das ist wahnsinnig einfach. Wenn man bei Spotify uns hört, braucht man nur einmal klicken auf die Bezahlschranke. Dann kommt man zu Steady oder man geht einfach auf unsere Homepage. neuezwanziger.de, dort ist ein goldener Salon-Button. Auf den klickt man und dann kann man sich eines der Pakete bei Steady raussuchen. Ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Und man hat dann auch Zugang zu dem gesamten Archiv. Bei Apple hat man natürlich auch Zugang zu unheimlich vielen Folgen. Und dann gibt es noch für diejenigen, die bei Patreon schon angemeldet sind und die nicht noch einen weiteren Anbieter abonnieren wollen, die Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast auch bei Patreon zu abonnieren. Das ist also die Möglichkeit zugleich, unseren Podcast auch zu unterstützen und damit auch ein bisschen die Unabhängigkeit stark zu machen, die ja eigentlich das Podcast-Business ausmacht. Verweist doch bitte nochmal auf diesen herrlichen Podcast, den du schon gepostet hattest, wo man nochmal ein bisschen die Genese des Podcast-Business, das anfangs gar kein Business war, nachvollziehen kann, um nochmal klarzubekommen. Ja, Podcast meint jetzt nicht einfach, dass alle großen Medienhäuser Radio veranstalten, sondern meint eigentlich eher so was, wie wir das hier tun.
Ja, lasst euch nicht lumpen. Ein Podcast, was ist ein Podcast? Und dann kann man das mal sagen, ja, also irgendwie so ein Medienangebot. Aber die beste Definition von Podcast aus dem Gespräch, ich sag gleich, wo es stattfand, ist, ein Podcast ist vom Nutzer aus gedacht, wenn man hört, wo immer du deinen Podcast hörst oder wo immer du Podcast hörst, kriegst du diesen Podcast, dann ist es ein Podcast. Also es gibt keine Sendezeit. Es gibt keine Nummer auf einer Fernbedienung, hinter der sich das verbirgt. Und dann kriegt man es nur dort, sondern ist es überall verfügbar.
Nicht nur auf einer Plattform.
Genau, man hört das mit seinen eigenen Gerätschaften. Ob man dafür bezahlen muss oder nicht, ist zweitrangig. Hauptsache, man kriegt ihn überall und selbstbestimmt und ohne noch mal ein Werbetoken oder so was hinterlassen zu müssen. Ich war hier, ich hab und so weiter. Sondern ein Podcast ist frei verfügbar und kostet manchmal Geld, weil er in der Herstellung auch Geld kostet. Dieses Gespräch fand statt im The Verge Podcast. Also im Podcast von The Verge. Vergecast heißt der Podcast. Den gibt es schon seit 2011. Das ist ziemlich alt. wir haben jetzt am Wochenende in Berlin die Subscribe. Das ist eine Podcastkonferenz.
Aber die Folge ist neu jetzt zu dem Thema.
Die Folge ist neu, genau. Das ist die aktuelle Folge des Vergecasts. Und David Pearce hat da den Podcast, der Podcast-Geneese ist da nochmal nachgegangen. wir haben jetzt am Wochenende die Subscribe in Berlin. Eine Konferenz der freien Podcast-Szene, der wir uns auch angehörig fühlen, die leider nicht so gut besucht ist wie zuletzt 2019 vor der Pandemie. Also die Community wird jetzt auch so ein bisschen mal wieder wachgerüttelt am Wochenende. Ich gebe mir da auch mit Mühe. Willkommen, also bin ich ziemlich sicher am Ende des Monats ohnehin noch mal auf Podcasterei und so einen etwas freieren Kunstbegriff und Kultur. Also Frank Schetzing ist gerade vor mir die Treppe runtergefahren und hat den rebellet-t-shirt an. Und ich habe aber nirgendwo Rebellen gesehen und ich denke, wenn wir jetzt Subscrib, Podcastkonferenz und Buchmesse haben in einem Monat, kann man auch noch mal kurz reflektieren, wie der Stand der Nation gerade ist.
Prima, wir hören uns also dann erst mal am Ende des Monats in der regulären Folge und dann im Salon sprechen wir dann unter anderem sehr ausführlich über Verlust von Andreas Reckwitz. Und das können wir auch schon mal ankündigen. wir wollen dann im Salon im November die Termine bekannt geben für die vier Salons im nächsten Jahr in der Case, also dann in der kleinen Räumlichkeit, sage ich mal, verglichen mit dem Saalbau, also mit 200 Leuten. Dort wird es also wieder vier Termine geben, immer einmal im Quartal. Und diese Termine geben wir dann bekannt und wie man an Karten kommen kann. Das alles dann im November Salon. Insofern lohnt sich das Abonnieren.
Sehr gut. Genau. Bis dann.
Bis dann.